kristen thank you very much 85 degrees
remember that number because that was
the official high for the day today and
guess what
that tied the record for this date that
was set back in 1980 we were talking
about these
record temperatures lately especially
for the first week of november can you
believe it
and that will continue through the work
week 78 in centenni hills right now
someone here at 75
80 for aliante we head on over the east
side sunrise mountain 87
along with green valley henderson how
about 77 for you rhodes ranch mountains
edge 84.
seven hills just shy of 80 degrees that
also includes
southern highlands there too and also
mountains edge there
89 for death valley 78 for prom 77
boulder city
88 for laughlin right now warm
conditions all across the
region warmer than average for sure
doppler network again dry after
some showers we had yesterday and storms
that were in utah
and also in northern arizona
northwestern arizona that's over and
done with now
now we're watching a pair of systems
that are out in the pacific right now
coming in from the gulf of alaska
carrying some cold air along with this
moisture very limited
but the possibilities out there
futurecast look at this very bullish as
far as giving us rainfall on saturday
there are only slight chances for
showers here and also the mountains
the second one behind that one i
pinpointed out to you gives us another
chance on
sunday so we have two chances here a
better chance will be on sunday and that
could end our record dry streak
which is right now at 198 days straight
with no
measurable rain gusty winds expected
friday too wind alerts may be needed it
will be breezy on saturday and sunday
here's the forecast overnight nice and
mild 60 degrees overnight
cool clear light winds expected and then
tomorrow
still light winds for us tomorrow record
heat though again 84 degrees or high
that will
tie the record set back in 1980.
here's your extended forecast now like
we said big winds on friday that
includes saturday two
and then a huge temperature drop 85 to
61. look at that
temperature drop daytime highs chilly
next week though
only those high 50s and cold overnight
that's your most accurate forecast
denise
all right